this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by you we don't do any
advertisement so if you'd like to
support the show just visit the
minimalists calm a slash support enjoy
the show
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green you know I bet that
you'll be fine without hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Millburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists we're back baby
we are back welcome to episode 27 we're
gonna talk about passion today and Ryan
we should probably start off you and I
were having this conversation off air I
be on air right now anyway what's your
question there's air all around us wow
man that's so deep so passionate about
air you know I mean I I was I've been
off coffee for the last week and I'm
finally back on right now so I'm feeling
really good nice looking really good
yeah I mean I tell you what so Ryan and
I were on this crazy tour we brought our
documentary which is called minimalism a
documentary about the important things
all over the United States and Canada
and along with over hundreds of
screenings we went to 13 of them
ourselves and and got up and talked
different audiences we did live versions
of our podcast some of those are still
forthcoming but you know I really
drained my adrenals I was having adrenal
fatigue after the tour tour how many
cups of coffee do you think you have a
day you know I I have far fewer now than
I did back in the corporate world back
in the Corporal you remember this I used
to have about a dozen cups a day but
they were the they weren't it wasn't
cups they were the big cups they were
the the Viennese for the 20 ounce cups
and and and well first off it was often
Starbucks that was my first problem and
and you know III had a ton of coffee I'm
really passionate about coffee you and I
opened a coffee shop with some friends
down in st. Petersburg the little world
you were more passionate about caffeine
well I was so much passionate as I was
addicted
I'm not passionate about heroin I mean
I'm not addicted yes
any time you're passionate passionate
about something and it's in as
detrimental to yourself or others then
that can be problematic although I think
passion is really one half love one half
obsession but it has to be healthy
obsession you can't end up like Howard
Hughes peeing and mayonnaise jars in
your room because you're so obsessed
about about something and so I found
that with coffee yeah I went way past it
went way way way past passion and and
and an excitement for that thing it was
I need this to survive so I remember
when I was 28 years old I I gave up
coffee it was giving it up for 10 days
because you can do anything for 10 days
and by day 3 I had to go home from work
and I was in the fetal position at home
and I just I couldn't I couldn't deal
with going from a hundred to down 2-0
cups a day I had a legitimate caffeine
addiction but since then my caffeine
intake has improved significantly I have
won the three cups a day now and never
go past that that three mark and so when
we're on tour it's generally three cups
every single day but it's that on top of
us doing these these crazy shows in
front of sold-out crowds and we have a
lot of people were interacting with and
answering questions and we give out
thousands of hugs and Ron tour and it's
amazing in the moment you've got that
adrenaline but that adrenaline when it's
overused leads to adrenal fatigue so
flash forward to the end of the tour we
got back here to Missoula Montana I said
you know I I got this advice from
several people on the road in fact
Justin the the posture guy he was in our
LA oh yes yes I think he's the posture
guy calm he's helping with some back
exercises and and he did a podcast about
letting go of coffee for a week and and
so he recommended it I had someone else
recommend it on the road and then Becca
my partner who is a nutritionist and a
dietician she she was like you know if
you have adrenal fatigue which it looks
like you do I would definitely just
recommend no caffeine over the course of
a week and it was pretty difficult
although I stayed really hydrated and
and so I didn't have those same caffeine
headaches I would have and now I came
back to it and I feel great but just
having a little bit of caffeine and not
relying on I have to have two cups to
get my day started
I am Akshay back yesterday was yesterday
yeah how was that first cup of coffee it
was delicious
no I made it a home with dog with coffee
yes by the way that's where all the best
coffee is in Missoula it's either in
Josh's kitchen or mine there are some
decent shops here zoo town yes in
particular but we would joke well we're
on the road we're on a coffee tour and
we just happen to go around and give
talks as well and and so that's
something we're really passionate about
but today we're gonna talk about passion
and what does that mean and Ryan and I
were talking off air I'm circling back
to this now we were talking off air
about this concept of passion and it's
just so overused right yeah I mean and
it puts so much pressure on people well
it really does because we we hear this
advice you should follow your passion
we're at the cue the music Sean no III
think I it's propagated this message we
see it in a lot of self-help books
especially some vapid self-help books
but even some well-intentioned well done
self-help books it sounds good we've
been told this thing follow your passion
we were at the at NPR and Missoula last
time we were there and they have this
success erease kind of poster there that
it even says follow your passion so
they're looking at college graduates on
it right yeah yeah so this is at the
college here at the University only way
to follow your passion is to go to
school and pay for it right spend your
money follow your passion and so you
know I I hear this advice and well I
know it's well-intentioned I think it's
crappy advice
we have article at our website if you go
to the minimalists comm slash Cal
C al it's an interview we did with a guy
named Cal Newport who is a professor at
a Georgetown and he's written several
books most notably deep work and and so
called he yeah so good they can't ignore
him yes so good they can't ignore you
and and we interviewed him there and in
the title of that is
follow your passion is crappy advice and
and the reason that it's crappy advice
is it presupposes you were born with
with a passion
if presupposes you were born to be a
yoga instructor or an astronaut or a a
gardener or whatever you were supposed
to do with your life you're born to do
this thing but the truth is there are
dozens of things you can be passionate
about and so today we're as we're
talking about passion think about about
passion more in line of creativity or
craft or or sometimes even vocation or
we even talked a little bit about
mission today I hope as well so we're
talking about passion you don't have to
think about it in the nebulous sense you
can get more specific about it in fact
we get this question all the time right
Ryan what do you do it's the first
question that people ask you when you
meet them what do you do and they're
really looking for what's the title in
your business card it's a really broad
question because I mean the truth is
that you do plenty of things Ryan what
do you do
I'd snowboard that's fun I do podcasts
but when you tell people you snowboard
they're like wow I mean I had this the
other day I was at a dinner and it was
like a really really nice dinner it was
an event for like a charity event for
the symphony here the local symphony
that our friend Darko orchestrates but
uh I'm sitting at the table and that's
like the first question that the the guy
next to me asked and he didn't mean
anything
you know bad by the question but it was
just like hey what do you do and I'm
like you know what I love to do I love
to snowboard I'm right I'm really bummed
that there's no snow in the mountains
right now and we had this like wonderful
conversation about snowboarding and
skiing for like the next 20 you know 25
minutes and then he like got up and he
was actually the Somali ather so like he
had to get up and like you know do an
introduction as he was getting up and
walking to the stage and the event was
getting ready to start his girlfriend
looks over at me she's like so what do
you actually do though like for a living
it is funny how they people are so
they're so
yeah interested in what you how do you
make money hey how do you make money and
that's weird and that's what we don't
posit the question that way but if we
really said if we really sat down with
someone and said hey where do you work
how much money do you earn so I can
compare you to me on the socio-economic
ladder or I can think back when we were
in in Toronto it was our last tour stop
we did a Q&A at the end we did a podcast
as when we came up and asked us so
what's your net worth and how much do
you make a year yeah it was that one and
and what and what I told her is you know
basically a that's the wrong question
but B my net worth doesn't determine my
actual worth and I think that that's
where we that's what we need to tweeze
out and understand that that yes you can
see what my you actually can see down to
the penny what my retirement looks like
if you go to the minimalists comm slash
retirement so it's not like I'm trying
to hide that we're pretty transparent
about about many of the things that we
do but it's not the primary focus of
what we do in terms of I'm going to do
this so I can make money really what I'm
attempting to do with everything we do
with the minimalists is how do we add
value to other people's lives and I know
that that phrase has stuck with me over
the years and so much so that it has
become a visceral sort of emotional
response to things is this adding value
to other people's lives and does it add
value to my life as well and I can't
keep giving without getting as well so
we have we have to have both there but
when she asked that question it that was
the most honest way to actually ask what
do you do yeah because that's that's the
intention behind the question so what
you what you talked about he said I love
snowboarding or I'm passionate about
snowboarding I call that turning a verb
I'm sorry turning a noun into a verb so
instead of talking about what you do to
earn a living we all have to make a
paycheck I totally understand that we
all have bills but it may not may or may
not be the thing we're passionate about
and so I found that I instead of saying
here's my title here's my noun but
here's my now and answer I'll give you a
verb answer I'm really passionate about
writing is what I'll tell people in fact
that's how I I dislocated myself from
the need to tie myself to the the job
title and being able to talk about what
I was passionate about and then that
allowed you to have a whole conversation
about oh yeah passion about snowboarding
what are you passionate about and so
we're talking today about passion please
think about it and in other terms that
you may feel more comfortable with if
you feel great with passion then great
if it's better with creativity or what's
your craft or what do you enjoy
sometimes it's what are your hobbies
that's fine you get the frame and
however you want I know when people ask
Mariah that question she's just like oh
well you know I able at this
you know I ear nose and throat doctors
office but like every time she get asked
ask that every time she gets asked that
question I can just see this look over
her face like okay let's get this out of
the way so we can talk about something
else because she doesn't want to talk
about work who really does I mean very
few people want to talk about their work
right unless it's your mission which
which we'll talk about here in a second
our first voicemail today is from Connor
in Toronto I just turned 17 so as a
teenager I'm pretty unsure of what I
want to do as a career I have several
interests and hobbies but I don't have
that one thing I'm good at
that defines me really I like
photography a lot in computer design but
I don't make the time to pursue these
for a passion since I'm in high school
and I also work as a lifeguard and a
first-aid instructor how can I
effectively make time and just focus on
one passion congratulations for asking
this question at age 17 Ryan I really
wish that I was asking these questions
at age 17 at 17 I was just so focused at
getting out of high school I didn't go
on to the to the college route I was so
focused on getting out of high school
getting a sales job so I could start to
earn more money than my parents ever had
yeah I wish I had the ya know how to ask
these quality questions instead of ya
just how am I gonna make a living oh my
god I'm leaving my parents house how am
I gonna survive on my own I got to make
money at any cost
yeah you're so far ahead right now
Connor and so really what you're trying
to figure out is how do I make time for
a passion but the other part of that is
how do i how do I find a passion you say
you have a lot of interests a lot of
hobbies yeah like photography and
computer
design you're also a lifeguard which is
definitely something you can be
passionate about you didn't say whether
or not you're passionate about it maybe
it's something you can cultivate into a
passion or you also said you're a
first-aid instructor and so that may be
something you can cultivate into a
passion as well or maybe those are just
vocations that help you pay the bills
and and and that's great too
so how do you make time well it's really
about priorities you can you can sit
down you can take a look at your day how
do you spend your 24 hours because we
don't all have the same resources but we
all have one resource in common it's the
same 24 hours in a day now Connor
obviously you have to go to school
you're probably finishing up school
right now and then how are you spending
your remaining hours we have 168 hours
every single week where you're gonna
spend some of those sleeping you're
gonna spend some of those at school or
work but then quite often we're gonna
spend many of those hours on television
ooh you know the average person writes
all the stat recently 15.7 years of our
life 15.7 years of our life is spent
watching television Wow 15 years of
television non-stop that's crazy it's
unbelievable you're attempting to
cultivate into a passion so what I was
saying earlier about Cal and and how
follow your passion is bad advice well
the better advice then is cultivate your
passion find something that you're
interested in but also something that
aligns with your values your beliefs
your ethics your morals and something
that you could see yourself doing a year
from now two years from now and see
whether or not you can cultivate that
into a passion and it may not always
work the good news is for Conor he's
young but even if you're not young even
if you're 40 or 50 or 60 you can start
cultivating a passion and that might
change over time the thing you're
passionate about today you may not be
passionate about tomorrow and so you
want to you you want to keep questioning
is this the thing that I want to
continue to focus on to cultivate into a
passion but the key here Conor for you
is to pick one thing and and then
attempt to do it well and over the over
time you will get better at it you say
you don't have that one thing that
defines you right now that's a good
thing I don't want one thing that
defines me either
again I don't want that now
I want to be able to give verbs to
people when they ask me what do I do
what am i passionate about yeah and the
good news is Connors you have two things
that you've already kind of narrowed it
down to photography and I think he said
computer programming computer design
computer design so right there I mean
you you have two things in there way
down to choose one and you know what
there may not be one that stands out
above the other that you may have to
drop two names in the Hat and pick one
out but yes definitely choose one and
and just the kind of echo what Josh said
I would challenge you Connor to find at
least an hour a week to start focusing
on those things if not an hour a week at
me an hour a day I mean Josh I know back
in the corporate world he wanted to
write and looking at his schedule he had
no free time he was literally you know
getting up answering email taking a
shower going whatever going throughout
his day did not eat the hours a week
yeah 80 hours a week so what did you do
Josh I instead of getting up at 5:45 in
the morning I would get up at 4:44 I had
my alarm set every morning for 444 a and
that was really easy to write like you
just jumped out of bed every morning I
decided to do it no no it's especially
when I was getting very very little
sleep and now it's not like we're
advocating getting less sleep
necessarily but something else is going
to have to give especially if it's just
for a short period of time and you can
see an outcome that's gonna come later I
knew for me that it wouldn't it wouldn't
be where I was continuing to work 80
hours a week in perpetuity I knew that
I'd be eventually working toward
becoming a full-time fiction author and
it happened to be nonfiction with this
whole blogging and minimalists thing but
but I knew that I was working towards
something as opposed to just depriving
myself for a extended or nebulous period
of time yeah the other thing to Connor
and you know I don't know what high
school you go to or you know what kind
of programs they offer because it's
Hirano high school one high school or
they have only one high school that he
replaced his modifier yeah I would say
take advantage of the courses you have
man you know I don't know if you got
photography courses there in high school
we had a few to choose from I know a lot
of high school kids who have computer
design courses or a computer
programming courses or whatever use the
tools you have available to you if you
don't have those tools then yes I would
challenge you to find at least an hour a
week I know you can find an hour a week
there's definitely can and then as your
as time goes on in your schedule frees
up then besides adding you know an extra
hour of this or an extra hour of that
think about how you can add more hours
of cultivating whatever it is you choose
to cultivate and even if it's not in
high school this is for someone else out
there there are a lot of community
classes community seminars places where
people go to gather and and share their
interests their hobbies their maybe a
photography school locally you can
connect with people there you can
connect with people locally who are
already passionate about the thing that
you are considering cultivating into a
passion and if you're looking forward to
connect with some like-minded or
open-minded people in your area you can
just go to minimalist org we have a
hundred free local meetup groups in a
hundred different cities in eight
countries also there's a online city too
so you can have other people there to
help hold you accountable for for
cultivating your passion and making sure
your you're doing something toward that
every week or ideally every day if
possible
our next voicemail is from David in
Dallas keep asking the question what is
our passion what is my passion I
currently don't know what that is and
how does one find a passion is it a
matter of time or should i dial in
several hobbies until something just
clicks and my issue with that is trying
to be a minimalist I just feel that
continuous search for something until it
clicks you still so you know non
efficient and it bothers me because it
is just time-consuming and mentally
exhausting for that just long search of
what is my passion so I guess what I'm
saying is how does one start the search
or what are the steps to cultivate this
passion I like a lot of things I just
don't know what I like to the point of
pursuing it and I played an
since that I've played all my decisions
in life
fairy faith I meaning personally I would
have loved to studied film but since I
don't know that's my pass or not I went
ahead and studied business and I'm tired
of playing it's a first thing you're
gonna have to do is identify what your
values are now everyone has certain
basic human needs a need for shelter and
for food and for clothing but once your
basic human needs are met then you have
to figure out what are the what are your
higher order values in life what what is
most important to me and Ryan and I
wrote about this in our first book so
David I love to send you a copy of that
book it's called minimalism live a
meaningful life there's an entire
chapter on passion and creativity in
there it's the third the third value
that we mentioned so we go through what
we identified once we got the clutter
out of the way for us Ryan and I
identified five different areas there
were our values these higher order
values we just called them the five of
values of living a meaningful life so
first off was health second
relationships third was passion fourth
and fifth they kind of go together
growth and contribution and so we
identified those are our values and so
when you're looking to pick a passion
you want to make sure it aligns with as
many of those values as possible and
then you can also add your own values
well what are your what are your beliefs
what are your own morals what do you
find interesting you said you have a lot
of things that you like David well which
of those things aligns most
significantly with with your values and
also the question is is this something
I'm going to want to make money from a
long-term meaning do I want to turn this
into a vocation if so how possible is
that what are the templates out there
when I was leaving the corporate world
people didn't believe I was leaving it
at first right now I would tell people
that when I was leaving because I had
this prestigious job title as the
director of operations for 150 retail
stores but that wasn't
yeah I I was pretty good at it and so I
I they all assumed I was going to a
competitor and I said well no I'm just
gonna go right full-time and you know I
probably work at a coffee shop down the
street just to pay the bills and I just
really wanted to write literary fiction
that was my thing and and so I
identified that as as my passion so when
I finally decided to make that leap step
away from the corporate world I was told
by so many people you can't just go be a
writer but then if if anyone could do
that well then everyone would do it you
can't just go make a living as a writer
and I just thought to myself wait a
minute
there are thousands of people probably
tens of thousands of people who make an
income from writing and so that's that's
silly what was happening is people were
projecting their own fears their own
insecurities onto me he's gonna go do
the thing he wants to do I don't feel
comfortable enough in making that leap
and going and doing the thing that I
want to do because of X Y & Z don't let
other people project their fears I knew
that there was a model way template out
there so if you are wanting to cultivate
a passion into something that earned you
an income that's that's great it doesn't
have to certainly doesn't have to be
that way but if you want to do that find
a template find a model find someone
else out there who has cultivated a
passion and turned it into an income and
you can certainly find those people
there there are plenty whatever you want
to do I'm willing to bet you there is
someone who does that thing very well
and gets compensated for it yeah you
know one thing that David said that kind
of oh I don't want to say rings alarm
bells but it just concerns me a little
bit when he said well you know I just I
have all these passions and I sit there
and I just think about you know stuff
until you know I'm just waiting for
something to click and that is that is I
think that's the wrong approach and the
reason why I say that is because you
know we have this idea that we can sit
around and I was listed well I got this
from Tim Ferriss I was listening to one
of his podcast the other day and he was
talking about how people
sit around trying to discover themselves
and it's not about discovering yourself
as much as it is creating yourself and
many of you probably heard this this
saying before discover yourself don't
discover yourself create yourself but
what that means is that you can't
journal your way to a passion there
isn't a test that you can take that's
gonna say hey thanks for taking this
test here's here's your passion you want
to be a veterinarian and that's what
you're gonna be passionate about the
rest of your life
I feel like high school counselors try
to do that well they try to give you
some guidance I mean that's what they
our guidance counselors and certainly
you know they want to give you some
options but unfortunately there isn't a
test and the thought behind this
discovering yourself is basically kind
of looking at yourself like a block of
ice like well you know if I read this
book then I'm gonna like chip a little
piece away and if I talk to this one
person I'm gonna chip a little bit more
way and eventually I'm gonna reveal
myself and and a and again that is not
how it works instead of looking at it
like you're a block of ice or look at it
like you're you're discovering yourself
David look at yourself like you're a
little ball of clay and that's it and
you have to add little pieces to that
ball of clay and yes reading a book or
journaling or thinking about it will
certainly help you to start to head or
will be those little pieces that you're
adding but those cannot be the only
pieces that you you add to yourself so
what I would say David is this man
choose one thing if you if you have 20
things 40 things whatever it is write
them all down and right away you're
gonna know you're gonna know what you're
gonna know that okay I can cross off
lacrosse off this list or I can cross
off milk chugging contests off the list
like I mean they're gonna be some
automatic things that you can cross off
and then if you've got ten left over
even if it is still 20 left over put
them all on a hat and just choose one
and do that one thing and do lots of it
over and over again and you know what
you might fail you might find something
that you you pick up on and you're
you're committing to every single day
and realize you know after six months of
really committing really drudging
through the drudgery that man I really
don't like this and you might fail and
that's okay because I can tell you that
the more you fail the more successes you
have also that is a ratio that holds
so work towards your passion David and
become an expert at it
our next voicemail is from Jesse in
Washington DC how do you find what your
mission is in life and how do you
translate that into a paycheck or does
it have to translate into a paycheck
because at the end of the day like you
say we all have to keep our lights on so
Jesse I just want to talk about my story
in minimalism because I do look at at
minimalism and sharing this message as a
mission of mine and the way that it
started was an interest it started with
one interest just a little bit I saw
this significant difference in Josh I
saw him acting differently and I went to
him like hey what the hell is going on
with you and he told me about this thing
called minimalism and then showed me an
entire community of people who called
themselves minimalists and that
interested me it drove me to want more
like a lot more so I was like great I'm
on I want to be a minimalist too I want
to do this I didn't think in my head
like okay how am I gonna make money off
of this okay I want to be a minimalist
but how can I make money off of this it
didn't work that way it was it was okay
I want to be a minimalist what what can
I do to pursue this path so we came up
with the idea of the packing party and
if you haven't heard of the packing
party you can go to the minimalists
dot-com slash packing or you can check
out Ryan I did a TEDx talk a few years
ago so the minimalist column slash TEDx
or you can just find it over on on the
youtubes they they have it over there a
few million people have watched it at
this point
yeah so after that packing party I was
like wow
here's some amazing lessons that I've
learned during this adventure here's
some amazing lessons I've learned during
this experiment so I went to Josh and
I'm like hey man we could probably share
this with others because oh by the way
one of my other passions something that
I really loved was helping people change
their perspective for the better like in
the corporate world I love taking you
know Johnny jump
a sales guy who was getting ready to get
fired because the salespeople had a
great name Johnny jump up Johnny jump up
Suzy's something but no like you know
taking an employee who was getting ready
to get fired
taking them in to my office and you know
having a conversation with them and
really listening to them seeing where
there were their issues lied or you know
what was going on helping them solve
those issues to the point of you know
the following a month of the month after
them winning employee of the month I
really really loved helping people
change their perspective that way for
the better so of course I'm like dude we
can help change people's perspective
with this packing party story so we came
up with the minimalists dot-com it was a
great it was a great thing for us to do
at the time because a we were passionate
about minimalism and I really wanted to
help as many people as I could change
their perspectives people who were in
the same position as I was so then after
a year it was like a year before we made
any money on our blog on our blog at all
before we sold anything and it's because
people kept asking us you have a book
that we can we can buy and we're like no
we've just been writing you started out
as sort of this catalog of a journey so
we had your packing party on there this
21-day journey and I wrote some essays
and then we wrote some essays together
and it just sort of blossomed out of
that but the intention wasn't to go in
and make money it was trying to
contribute to the world around us in a
meaningful way and and so yeah buddy
about a year in we finally
self-published a book called minimalism
love a meaningful life the very first
edition of that which is a lot different
from the one that's out there now but
that was a result of of demand basically
so so we had added so much value upfront
people were saying yeah I'd like to find
a way to support you but I also like
this in a different form and so we we
published there was an e just an e-book
at the time and because we knew that
other people wanted that recipe our
recipe and they wanted it in
form and so it allowed us to yes
eventually start start earning some
income off of that but it wasn't the
primary driver right but it you know if
I came to you and I said you know Josh
why the hell are you so happy what's
going on with you and you were like oh
man there's this thing called minimalism
and you and I should put a business plan
together over it I don't I I really
really doubt we would have even gotten
this far with the message no I mean
you're absolutely right because
sometimes a business plan is necessary
for your operating expenses and capex
and all these things especially if you
if you're doing a normal brick and
mortar business but but the truth is
that that for us it wasn't about going
into business the business resulted from
from finding something that we were able
to cultivate into a passion I had a
passion for writing you had a passion
for contribution and sort of marrying
those things together and it's not like
you weren't passionate about writing I
wasn't passionate about contribution
there are many things were passionate
about but these are the things that we
were most passionate about so when you
brought Suzy salesperson into your
office and helped her become you know
the President's Club winner that year
you you you saw someone turning around
and also make it a change in her life a
pivot in her life that would pivot 15
degrees and you see you'd see a year
from then or two years from that change
she's in a dramatically different
location and it's helping her and her
family her kids are doing better because
of what you've been able to contribute
to her life the value you you've been
able to add to her life
the only thing Ryan that I would add to
to Jesse's question here is let's define
what mission is for people too so we
talked earlier what passion is for me
passion is one-half love plus one-half
obsession a healthy obsession obviously
but it needs to be something that you
get obsessed with over time it doesn't
mean you like every morsel of it because
you won't think about the people you
love the most do you like every single
thing they do I know I hate when Ryan
chews on his fingernails as I'm chewing
on my fingernails sorry I'm just on the
edge of my seat with this podcast you
know I I love Ryan dearly and and there
are certainly things that I know he
loves me too but but there are certainly
things that
he doesn't like about me he doesn't like
some of my OCD tendencies 1 2 3
and I I but I love every piece of him
and so I think it's same thing with
passion can you can you love the entire
the entirety of writing yes but you can
certainly dislike certain aspects of
writing for me I disliked getting up at
4:44 before going to work every day but
it was part of the deal I made with
myself to cultivate that passion and so
that's what a passion is now a mission
is just passion plus vocation that's
that's how I identify it so if you're
one of those people who is able to
cultivate a passion like Ryan has a
passion for snowboarding when he was
when when people ask me what do you do
and he says I'm passionate about
snowboarding they're like you make money
you're a professional snowboarder I'm
like no I just really like it no but
that'd be awesome if I could but no yeah
I really like it so you you don't have
to be you don't have to make a living or
turn it into a part-time or full-time
vocation you don't turn into a business
or anything anything you're passionate
about but if you're talking about
turning it into your mission so that you
can focus more time on it contribute to
more people on a greater scale then
quite often what we're just talking
about is turning your mission also into
your vocation and so so keep that in
mind when you're picking what your
passion is ask yourself can I turn this
into a mission long-term and if so embed
yourself yourself with people who who
are using that passion right now for
their mission in life as well our next
question is from Tara in New York City
I'm an advertising media planner I know
I'm the worst I like my job but it's
generally non creative work and I'm
naturally a creative person so I
simultaneously have all kinds of other
passions and side projects working on a
book for blog pieces for online and
print hub and illustration Commission's
I feel like I'm trying to do it all but
it's backfiring I don't want to be hate
just one thing but all of these things
demand a massive amount of my time and
focus which is one that is to begin with
my life right now is a stressful slew of
half-finished projects do you have any
tips on prioritizing your time to juggle
projects and disallow distractions all
the while not minimizing the things that
you truly love and live for you don't
have to pick one thing I think that's a
good news here but you do have to pick
one thing at a time when Ryan and I
first started the minimalists comm six
years ago almost now we started
simplifying our lives over six years ago
we started this this website we
certainly didn't go into it as Ryan said
earlier with a business plan for here's
all of the B tentacles this thing is
going to grow over the years no we
started writing essays we didn't even
know they were called blog posts at the
time we started writing essays and
putting them up online and eventually
over time we we wrote a book and then we
wrote a second book called everything
that remains and and and throughout that
journey we continued to add on to the
foundation we build and so since the
inception we've we've written hundreds
of essays about minimalism but we also
started this podcast we've contributed
in a bunch of different ways we've
toured all over the place and we even
just put out a documentary recently but
the key for us has been to focus on one
thing at a time and for us it's one
thing a year we tend to pick one major
project a year and then all of our
efforts need to coordinate to to
contribute to that one focus for the
year and so I'll give you a few examples
real quick as we look toward the horizon
it's always a year ahead for us so back
in in 2013 Ryan and I started a
publishing company with our friend Colin
Wright called asymmetrical press and
that publishing company was to really
just publish our own print books and
ebooks and audiobooks and Collins as
well and then we also have helped a few
authors along the way but also have
given guidance to a lot of other
creative people to show them that it's
possible to be an independent publisher
on your own of high quality work and so
we started asymmetrical press to do that
and we spent a year doing that and part
of that was was finishing our second
book everything that remain
and getting that out to the world and
then in 2014 Ryan and I decided to
donate a year of our lives 10 months to
be exact we went on a crazy hundred city
tour eight countries 119 events they
were all free and what we did is we hit
the road for almost an entire year just
to spread the simple living message and
that was our focus for an entire year so
we went on the road we did that we came
back and then last year 2015 well our
focus was a year of contribution we said
we want it we want to find a way to give
in a different way and inspire others to
give as well and so along with our
amazing audience we were able to take on
a bunch of philanthropic projects that
the really were the highlight of our
year so I'll go through a few of those
real quick we built some clean water
wells in Malawi four of them to be exact
for about 1,200 people in several
different villages there in Malawi we
funded an orphanage we helped build an
orphanage in Honduras with our friends
from the hope effect we built an
elementary school over in Laos where
Ryan just was over there in the fall for
the grand opening of of that and that
was amazing to see us be able to
contribute to 66 different kids and in
in Laos and we also funded a high school
for a year and we helped some folks open
a coffee shop in st. Petersburg Florida
and really it wasn't just a coffee shop
though the reason that was so appealing
is yeah we're passionate about coffee
that's great but it was a community hub
it was a beautiful space for creative
people to come together and organize and
have discussions and make the community
a better place and so we found ways to
contribute we spent a year contributing
and then this year which is 2016 our
main focus has been about the the
documentary that we just put out which
is in theaters and will be online pretty
soon and and we've focused all our
efforts efforts on that which means we
had to get good at saying no to a lot of
things anytime someone comes to us with
a new project or new idea it's not about
just saying no for the sake of saying no
that's it
idea but it's about saying no to the
things that don't add value to what your
main focus is so no Tara you don't have
to pick one one thing but you do have to
pick one thing at a time
focus on that build on top of it make
sure all your efforts go toward that one
thing and then you can add on in the
future well Tara asks you know how do i
how do i prioritize what are you
specifically how to how to prioritize
her time as she's juggling projects
let's think about juggling mmm I can
juggle I can juggle three balls he's
pretty good at juggling yeah I started
with two balls actually start with one
seriously
there were pool balls down in my
basement growing up then I started with
two and then I got the three and then I
felt like I've accomplished juggling and
I never went any further but let's say I
wanted to go further let's say I wanted
to get to like eight juggling you know
eight eight balls juggling and one chain
saw I'm getting to that
don't steal my thunder Melbourne yeah so
let's say I wanted to juggle eight balls
do you think I'd pick up five more balls
and just okay I can juggle three now I'm
gonna pick up five and learn how to
juggle eight that's a bad idea that's a
bad idea I probably learned how to
juggle four then I learned how to juggle
five yeah then I learn how to juggle six
and then eventually get to that eight
and then let's say I didn't want to
throw a chainsaw into that mix you think
I'm gonna throw a frickin chainsaw take
out one of those eight balls and replace
it with a chainsaw and tried to juggle
seven balls plus a chainsaw no I'm
probably gonna go back down to juggling
maybe two or three things or maybe just
with the chainsaw at first and then
adding a ball with the chainsaw so the
the question about juggling your
projects I mean you can look at it like
juggling yes you can absolutely do it
all but no you cannot do it all at once
and until you yeah practice and add on
to it as you go if you do decided the
chainsaw thing can you get life
insurance term life insurance yeah thank
you you're welcome Tara I'd love to send
you a copy of my favorite book of ours
it's a book called everything that
remains it's a memoir of the last five
years of our lives but it talks about
how we turn this thing we were
interested in in cultivated it into
a passion it started with writing and
then I really moved beyond that to to
contribution and marrying those two very
well and so it's a five-year narrative
and basically we went from these
suit-and-tie guys and in the corporate
world to becoming simple living
minimalist and to becoming the
minimalists over time and so I hope you
enjoyed that book Tara all right we'd
love to hear what you have to say if you
have a a comment about your passion or
your hobbies or creativity or craft or
if you have some minimalism tips on how
to cultivate your passion leave us a
voicemail at four zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine will air our
favorite comments and tips on the next
episode also Cullen Wright was on our
last episode Ryan we did a little I come
calling them guest casts I don't know if
that's trademarked but if so I'm
attending yeah pending the patent right
now
Cullen Wright who has the smooth this
radio voice he sounds so NPR slash p RI
slash ABC NBC CBS just what a great
voice but I love when we do these we've
done a few events with them quite a few
events in the past and we we have these
Q&A sessions afterward so if you have
specific questions for Colin as well and
you want to call in with those in the
future we'll do a another guest guest
cast with Colin where he just answers
some of your questions so if you call in
and have a question to say hey my
question is for Colin now we're gonna
what's gonna happen right because he his
voice is so smooth he's gonna get all
he's gonna Bogart all the questions I'm
sure but if you do have a question for
him about anything his podcast which is
called let's know things has been
blowing up on on iTunes and and all the
other places these kids get podcast
these days you know if you have a
question for him I'm sure he'd be happy
to answer we'll put together a future
episode a bonus episode with him all
right you know what time it is Milburn
what time is a it's time for our hashtag
ask the minimalists lightning round this
is where we answer questions from social
media we are on twitter and instagram at
the moon lists and facebook.com slash
the minimalists our first question
is from Jake who's from Fargo how do you
assess value from your passions
recommendations for metrics on how you
spend your resources on your passions
how would I answer this if I'm thinking
about my partner backs and if she were
to come to me and say can you quantify
on a scale of one to a hundred how much
you love me 110 right that's the
obligatory answer right but but but
you're gonna have to show also show me
the data behind this answer and the
truth is no it's just like it's like
love you you're going to know whether or
not you're passionate about something
the same way you know whether or not you
love somebody you have to be honest with
yourself and you have to constantly ask
that question am I still passionate
about this and too often we confuse
passion for excitement and that is a
dangerous trap this used to happen to me
all the time when I was an aspiring
writer which means I didn't write very
much but I would aspire every single day
and as is aspiration everywhere on the
shelves on the floor its aspiration
everywhere I went and and you know I I
would get I would aspire to write but
then I get this idea that for a novel or
a short story or something that was
really exciting to me and of course I'd
be exciting it with that excitement
would fuel me it's like a carbohydrate
it fuels me for a little while and it's
like a sugar rush but of course over the
the course of two or three days or maybe
a week or two weeks it was a really
exciting idea that excitement would wane
and it would get difficult I hit some
sort of roadblock and I'd say ah
obviously I'm not passionate about this
because I'm not still excited about it
well that's silly because because real
passion real excitement comes after you
put in the work after your after the
tedium and the drudgery and and being
willing to put in and exert the effort
the payoff is at the end of the work
it's not at the beginning and too often
we think well I'm just gonna because I'm
gonna find something that I'm passionate
about and I'm just going to be excited
and perpetuity it doesn't work that way
even with writing it did even now even
though I've cultivated that into a
passion it doesn't mean it's exciting
for me every day but you're gonna know
what what you're passionate about and
and then you need to work on cultivating
that passion yeah I guess Jake if I was
to give you like something to go off of
I mean first figure out what your values
are I mean Josh and I wrote about our
values we talked about him earlier in
the show we wrote about him in
minimalism live a meaningful life we've
got those five values so figure out what
your values are maybe they're the same
exact five values as ours that's okay
put those in a like an excel sheet sheet
type chart which I hate to like even
suggest like spread sheet just put them
in a spreadsheet yeah I don't want to
use that curse word I'm gonna say no
just just in a spreadsheet just across
the top just put those those values and
then on the left-hand side put down all
of your passions and then go across that
chart and mark which value each passion
kind of covers I had a close a student
do this a mentoring student do this just
last week I saw this and I'm like dude
I'm totally gonna steal this this is
actually not a terrible idea because he
was trying to figure out the same exact
thing he's like man I got about you know
eight passions I don't know what to to
choose and I'd like to you know instead
of putting them in the Hat maybe do it a
little bit more deliberately well what
he was able to do with this chart was
choose two things that fulfilled four
out of those five passions and it helped
him narrow it down to at least those two
and he ended up having to choose one
over the other I kind of random but that
might be something that that helps you
out Jake but ultimately yes I agree with
Josh you know there's not really a
metric to go off of but but certainly
that that chart or that spreadsheet or
whatever you want to call it could oh my
god this isn't explicit this is an
explicit podcast no I think I think that
will help you Jake the other thing that
will help you to love to send you a copy
of our book it's called essential
there's an entire
after on passion in there it's a
collection of about 150 essays that Ryan
I Ryan and I have written over the last
five years or so and and we put it into
twelve different chapters twelve
different ways to live a meaningful life
and one of those is passion so there's
an entire chapter in there and I think
you'll find some value in that all right
next question is from Justine I just
graduated college Congrats Justine need
help deciding should I live at home for
one year and pay off debt or should I
move back to LA and do what I'm
passionate about
Justine there is a bit of there's a
fault in your logic here you you are
presupposing that you can you either
have to go to LA to pursue your passion
or you have to pay off your debt my
answer to you is yes you should pay off
your debt first no matter what there's
no such thing as good debt debt is an
anchor it is in your way it's going to
prevent you from pursuing your passion
and living a life of freedom long term
but also but also that doesn't mean you
can't start cultivating a passion now
most passions are not geography is
specific in fact some geographies will
help augment that experience it will
help you cultivate your passion better
and that's great you can work toward
that but even before you move to LA you
want to make sure you have an emergency
fund saved up you have you can afford
moving to LA LA is pretty expensive I'd
love to live in LA too but if I did that
I'd have to change the way that my
finances are allocated because it would
cost more to live in LA than it would in
in Montana and so the question for you
is can I afford to move to LA right now
and the answer's no you have debt of
course you can't afford to move to LA
unless you have got some sort of great a
high paying job that align with your
interests then that would be a different
discussion it might make sense to do
that because it that would be geography
dependent but right now you have an
opportunity pet to pay off those debts
to to free yourself from those chains
and do that but along the way you can
start cultivating your passion you can
start working toward that that move to
Los Angeles yeah what a good point men
like how terrible would it be to
you know move to LA carry that debt with
you now you're living in a super
expensive place to live so now you've
put pressure on yourself to just afford
your bills to pay off that debt which
may totally you know increase the hours
you work a week I mean it could it could
be a very detrimental situation just
kind of throw yourself into it and say
oh I'll just I'll just pursue my passion
and pay off this debt and you may not
pursue your passion at all because
you're so busy trying to live and pay
off your debt alright next question is
from Stefan if I have one thing I'm
passionate about and one thing I'm good
at
which one should I focus on well it
really depends ideally you want to be
good at your passion but if you are good
at something else that you're not
passionate about because it doesn't
align with your values then that's a
problem and and I can speak from
experience here I was very good at my
corporate career I was very good at
climbing the corporate ladder so was
Ryan I mean we made it a very quick
career yeah and over the course of 12
years I climbed the ranks so much but
the closer I got to the people I really
aspired to be like you know I had a plan
to be a vice president by age 32 a
senior VP by age 35 that's weird Ryan so
I'll be 35 next week and and I guess I'd
be a senior vice president by now had I
stuck it out in the corporate world and
my plan was to be a c-level executive by
age 40
you know CFO or CEO Oh ideally probably
CEO oh and and and then maybe one day
CEO if I was if I was lucky and then you
get the you know if you get that c-level
you got the golden parachute but the
more the closer I got to those people as
I climb those rungs on the corporate
ladder I realized they weren't very
happy most of them and I think the
reason they weren't happy is because
they didn't find a lot of purpose or joy
or meaning a significance and in the
work that they did and and so I was
really good at being the director of
retail stores are running a bunch of
retail stores I was the best in our
company and and won a lot of President's
Club Awards and was certainly
compensated accordingly but it actually
got in the way of me pursuing what I was
passionate about and so I had to let
that go
eventually so I could find my passion
but then really dedicate the hours
necessary to cultivate that passion so
stuff and your question is if I'm
passionate about one thing and good at
another what should I do do the thing
that you're passionate about and become
good at it in time
our next question is from Evie how can
you keep your trinkets in check while
cultivating your passion stationary
sports materials etc how much is too
much
well Evie if you're asking that question
you probably got too much that's alright
I'll tell you what I do with my
snowboarding stuff so I'm very as
everyone knows I'm passionate about
snowboarding do we talk about that
enough on this podcast actually I kind
of love because like that actually will
be a conversation topic that a lot of
people will bring up when we're out on
the road so anyway
snowboarding with my gear I don't have
to snowboards I have one snowboard I
don't have two winter coats I have one
winter coat I don't have you know three
or four pairs of gloves for different
conditions like I have one pair of
gloves and a pair of liner gloves I
guess if you want to it's functional and
I use them every time I snowboard
well how many snowboards do I have yeah
just as your snowboards there's a reason
for that like it it doesn't add any
purpose for me I there's not a purpose
for it it's not gonna bring me joy I
would just get in the way for me I just
store it cuz I don't I don't enjoy
snowboard yeah but see what I used to do
though josh is I would have like let's
say one body like an $80 pair of goggles
and those are a year or two old
and those you know need to be replaced
or maybe I get a good deal on another
pair of goggles or something I would
like you know impulsively buy them and
then that old pair of goggles instead of
like donating them or you know giving
them giving them to a friend or
something that someone can use like I
would just hold on to them and I don't
even know why I would hold on to him it
was like this this feeling of well I'm
gonna hold on to it just in case like
these this pair of goggles breaks and I
have those to default to the ones that I
really don't like anymore anyways I can
always you know default to these
but but that's the type of thinking that
I would get trapped in and and this is
the same thing with passion like I can
only imagine
how an artist feels like when they see
people throw out a bunch of bottles it's
like oh my God look at all those bottles
I could create an amazing you know
project with all those bottles and
there's that impulse to like hoard all
of that and maybe they're really
passionate about you know making art but
the thing that I do is I have these
rules in place for myself that I will
not break some of those include the six
month rule josh has the 9090 rule you
know I will look at something and say
have I use this in the last six months
will I use it in the next six months if
the answer is no then I'm probably not
gonna hold on to it and guess what some
stuff I do hold on to thinking oh yeah
I'll use that in the next six months
well guess what when it comes back
around six months later and I'm asking
that question and I haven't used it well
then I don't even have to look six
months in in the future I know that
chances are I'm probably not gonna use
it so what I would say for you Edie is
create rules around how much of the
these stationary items you can you can
keep or how long you're gonna hold on to
these materials maybe it's six months
maybe it's a six month rule maybe it's a
ninety 90 rule maybe you've got a five
year rule maybe it's if you haven't used
in the last five years and you know are
you gonna use it in the next five years
I mean that covers a whole decade I
would not recommend that no you got to
start somewhere though but you got to
start somewhere yeah and that's just it
is is start with these rules and if
you're if you start to break the rules
then adjust the rules that are that are
gonna work for you most comfortably but
find a basis of rules that you can live
by that you can hold like gospel and
follow that that will certainly help you
to to not hold on to so much stuff and
and you could probably do some
decluttering after coming up with those
rules too right away and just remember
that minimalism is not about deprivation
but also sometimes constraints bring
life to creativity I'll give you a bit
of an example when we first started
building our our website we had no idea
how to create a website by the way we
put up a step-by-step process for anyone
who because we it's literally the number
one question we get is how did you guys
start your blog it's not about
minimalism
it's how did you start your blog and so
it just tells me that people like the
design and the simple the simplicity
of the template in the way that it looks
so if you're interested in and starting
your own blog you can go to the
minimalists comm slash blog you can see
exactly how we did it step by step
there's even even a video there but your
first designing it I'd seen a
placeholder for a logo so I opened up
apple pages and it's like the equivalent
of Microsoft Word maybe I will get Sean
to bleep that it's uh it's you know
essentially our Apple's word program and
I opened it up and created this
temporary logo in 15 minutes just as a
as a placeholder now I didn't have
InDesign or Photoshop or any of these
these apps that are required or I'm
saying required with local quotes here
to to be a graphic designer right I had
a lot of constraints all I have was this
word program and I made that quick logo
that placeholder logo for 15 minutes
well that's still the same logo we use
today and the reason that it's resonated
with a lot of people is I didn't have
all the the bells and whistles so to
speak
I think our logo wouldn't look as good
with a bell or a whistle and so it was
just an accidental placeholder I used
some fairly stock vector art I just in
fact I didn't even know it was called
vector art at the time i typed in people
silhouettes listening to this if you're
listening to this podcast right now you
can see our logo it's right there on on
your screen probably next to our heads I
just typed in you have people
silhouettes and it came back with a
bunch of like free vector art and then I
copied and pasted that into a a word
program and and that was a placeholder
but it has become a bit of an iconic
logo and we really still love it and a
lot of people have praised us for you
who did your logo I don't like oh man I
did I it's that that's the first and
only and last probably logo that I have
ever created and it's because I'm not
natural a designer but those constraints
giving myself
you have is this Apple pages document to
work from it allowed me to - forced me
actually to be more creative so I guess
what I would tell Evie is constrain
yourself sometimes and see how much that
brings your creativity to life all right
our final question our final question is
from Vanessa what do you do when a key
factor of a major passion starts to feel
more like a chore real quick Vanessa
here's what I do I Drudge through the
drudgery that's all you really can do
because again passion is not the same
thing as excitement when I first started
writing I wanted to put my head through
a wall 80% of the time but I was willing
to keep doing the work to keep drudging
through the drudgery because that extra
20% was the best feeling in the world
that was the real payoff so you have to
Drudge through the drudgery even now
writing for me is a chore 50% of the
time and I don't think it gets much
better than that so whatever your
passion is there are going to be chores
involved with that things that you don't
necessarily like to do but that's okay
because the real payoff comes once
you're willing to put in the work okay
now it's time for our added value
portion of the show this is where we
each recommend something that has added
value to our lives recently since we're
talking about passion today I'm gonna
recommend a book I just finished over
the weekend it was it was and is called
the Wright brothers so the Wright
brothers for those of you don't know
they invented the airplane back in well
so they're their fellow date onehans so
they have a special part and a special
place in my heart although they really
remind me of when I'm reading the story
Wilbur and Orville they remind me of me
and Ryan Ryan is my Orville to my Wilbur
I'll be warbles the Orville - sweet name
both names
so the Wright brothers the book is by
David McCullough it's a great biography
and
tell you the most inspiring thing to me
is one of the quotes in there Ryan he
so-so Wilbur in 1901 looked over at
Orville and he said they've been doing
experiments on trying to fly these
gliders and figure out how to do man
man-made flight he looked over at
Orville and said I don't think that man
is going to figure out how to fly in the
next 50 years
this is 1901 and then on December 17th
1903 they took their first flight so we
really radically underestimate what we
can do over the course of two years when
I look at what Ryan and I have done over
the last six years it has quite often
been in these two-year chunks where a
lot of things happen it's almost like
one year there's a lot of prep work and
then it's actually implementing the work
the following year but it's amazing to
see how much you can change over the
course of over two years and so the key
then is what it's to start today don't
wait until next year don't wait until
next month don't wait until next week I
I wish someone would have told me to
start a blog ten years before I did
because we would we would have been able
to contribute to so many more people
over that 10 year span and it's not just
incremental change when you share it
with someone and they share with two
people and those two people share it
with two people each it becomes
exponential over the course of time and
that's that's really been our greatest
social media button has been that
forward email button for everyone who
subscribed to our emails because we
don't ever send spam to anyone we just
plan to send our essays out to the world
and in our podcasts out to the world and
people tend to share it and that because
when you find value in something you you
want to give that to the people you care
about because you hope they'll get value
from it too and so I definitely
recommend the Wright brothers I think
that book is a portrait of true passion
true love and a obsession of aviation
and craft and I mean these guys were
just geniuses I definitely won a book so
1901 he was saying that we would never
fly ya there for 50 years I don't think
man's going to fly and then 68 years
later we were landing on
right that is crazy yeah and it just
goes to show I mean yeah there's yeah we
can accomplish a lot a lot more than we
think also from a fellow Ohioan Neil
Armstrong that's right yeah Lebanon Ohio
he lived in our lake home or like
hometown city yeah that's cool yeah so
the Wright brothers book check it out if
you get a chance Ryan I am going to
recommend an interview with Cal Newport
so if you are listening and you like
heard us talk about Cal Newport and
you've heard us recommend deep work or
so good they can't ignore you and you
don't really want to read those books
you can listen to this interview that
Cal Newport did on the art of charm that
will be in the show notes Shawn will put
that in there that's a good podcast
Jordan interviewer yeah it's a great
podcast because he talks about the deep
work and really what he means by that
but not only that I think the biggest
thing that like stood out to me in that
podcast was how how we have trained
ourselves to do a femoral work we have
trained ourselves to be reactionary and
went and when he said that and I looked
back at you know but my my days of
yesteryear and even over the last six
years you know fighting to keep these
habits consistent and to work on essays
and to work on you know books and this
and that
it is so easy to go to the ephemeral
stuff and the more time goes on well we
have more access to ephemeral things and
we really have to be careful with that
because we are training ourselves to do
the antithesis of deep work but there's
so many more nuggets in there than just
that but yeah check it out count
Newports interview on the art of charm
let's move on to right here right now
this is a Ryan and I we get to discuss
what's going on in the lives of the
minimalists now that we're back after
tour Missoula Montana we got a bunch of
stuff going on that I want to make you
aware of so first off coming very soon
we're gonna have some tour stops and
some fairly random places you'll see why
in a second we're going to be in Orlando
we're gonna be in Fargo and we're gonna
be in Europe now I'm going to keep it a
little bit vague there but let's go
through those quickly
was a horrible terrorist attack a lone
wolf terrorist attack in Orlando and so
we want to do something for Orlando yeah
we've talked about this before right
yeah thoughts and prayers aren't enough
I mean it can be a good start for some
people to share that sentiment but we
want to help out we want to go above and
beyond the thoughts and prayers right
and we want to encourage you all to do
that as well so we're gonna have a
charity event our distributor for our
film has agreed to do 100% of the
proceeds to that we're gonna donate all
of our proceeds as well from from that
event in Orlando we don't have a date
set yet but if you subscribe to our
email list over at the minimalists com
just type in your email there at the top
I will never send you spam but you'll
you'll you'll be kept posted on all of
our events so we're gonna do something
in Orlando also our coffee shop is about
two and a half hours from there in st.
Petersburg Florida I think we're gonna
do a special charity event while we're
in town there as well we're speaking in
July at TEDx Fargo Fargo North Dakota
we're coming back and and so we're gonna
screen our documentary there we're also
going to do a live version of our
podcast in both Orlando and Fargo don't
have the date for that yet but stay
tuned for that as well and then this
fall I think it's September there's
gonna be a UK and and maybe a couple
European dates as well so stay tuned for
that just for a couple more days at this
point so there's something called a
simple year that Ryan and I have been
involved with in the past so a few years
ago a friend of ours named Courtney
Carver she runs a blog called be more
with less she's also started something
called project 333 she started this this
12 months of guided simplicity program
now Ryan and I'll be the first to tell
you that you don't need a book or a blog
or a course to simplify your life but
sometimes we do need some help and if
you feel like you could benefit from 12
months of guided simplicity Courtney at
the beginning of each year does this
program with 12 different experts so
there's a month focuses on a different
aspect of simplifying your life whether
that's decluttering your house or your
wardrobe or your
car or travel or your work sometimes
your workspace she has all these
different ways to declutter your life
and she starts at the beginning of each
year with a bunch of different
simplicity experts we've contributed to
that in the past and this year she
decided to open it back up mid-year give
you full access to everything that's
going on earlier in the year and as you
get all the video work coursework all of
the the live interviews and stuff that
she has done with simplicity experts and
you get the live version for for the
rest of the year as well if you want
more details to that just go to the
minimalists comm /sy
we'll put that in the show notes as well
that's why it just stands for simple
year the minimalists comm /sy and you
can find 12 months of guided simplicity
for you also our documentary minimalism
is hitting theaters in Australia in July
and tickets are already selling like
crazy
it's very limited so most of those
screenings have either sold out or are
really close to selling out you can find
that also we release some new dates in
Canada finally coming to Saskatoon and
Regina but also we've we've added some
encore showings in Toronto and Halifax
and Vancouver and I think a few other
cities maybe Calgary and a few other
places as well all the details for that
as well as over a hundred other cities
going on right now in the United States
minimalism film comm over there you can
pre-order the film which comes out
August 2nd if you preorder it on Vimeo
which there's a link there you get six
hours of bonus interviews and content we
shot about a thousand hours when we film
this documentary but we wanted to make
sure that we so gave you the extra cream
that didn't make the cup so to speak and
so there's six hours of bonus content
they're gonna give you on August 2nd
lastly this is the the last chance we
still have a few seats for how to write
better if you're looking to improve your
your writing skills I teach a four-week
class called how to write better but I
and that goes on all the time but I
teach a one-day work
me and my adjunct professor professor
Sean mihalick we call him the other Sean
we have podcast Sean and we have other
Sean here and can only work for us if
your name is Sean yeah so you need some
sort of adjective before it though
spelled the right way - yeah so other
Sean will will be teaching that with me
he's sort of there helping along and
whenever I stutter or mumble he'll step
in but I have a lot of fun teaching this
workshop a lot of effort goes into it
and there's no cost very much but there
are a few seats left in there and that
is on June 26 2016 all the details over
at how to write better org and that's if
you want to improve your business emails
or your writing the Great American Novel
or you want to write a memoir or you
just want to improve your blogging
skills it's really really up to you how
to write better org you can find all the
details there finally here are some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners hello this is Jason Gardner my
comment is a great way to reduce my
April clutter is to journal and a great
way to journal is to use what I call the
brain dump and just dump what's on your
brain onto the page just to get it out
there and I do recommend writing it as
opposed to typing it or anything like
that but that's a personal choice
there's a good kinesthetic quality to
writing down things regardless using the
brain dump method it's a great way just
to get things onto the page and out of
the brain and reduce mental clutter my
name is Tom I'm from London this is in
response to last week's episode about
mental clutter I personally find it very
easy to remove physical clutter and
items in my life
to create space for more meaning and
value however while my exterior
surroundings have become more quiet and
calm my interior cut has become more
noisy and loud because I'm faced with
more provoking questions such as Who am
I without this item what will I do with
all the new time I saved and these
questions can become overwhelming for
some
so I second the advice rang and Josh
gave about finding someone in passions
talk to you such as a friend you can
trust or a professional like a therapist
my name is Jenna Vander lot I did want
to leave a comment because I just
listened to the last episode about
mental clutter and I am a graduate
student studying in counseling and I
heard one of the people that you one of
the comments when the show was about a
woman from Wisconsin where I'm from
dealing with some mental clutter and
some past trauma and I just wanted to
make a recommendation to her and to
anybody who else might be dealing with
that mental clutter that they treat the
relationships with the therapist that
they might seek out as any type of
relationship that they have in any other
part of their life to determine who has
what relationship has value sometimes
your first time with a counselor might
not be the right fit for you but you
should keep looking and treat it like
any other relationship then find someone
that really adds value to your life
because I guarantee you there's a lot of
people out there like me who would
really want to have the opportunity to
talk about any trauma that someone had
experienced or even just their journey
towards minimalism anything that comes
up for them and like you had said just I
had to talk about how making these big
changes really has affected your life as
a as a sounding board alright y'all
that's it for this episode if you have a
question for the minimalists give us a
call for zero six two one nine seven
eight three nine and if you leave here
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without every little feeling
that you got a hand
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for you got a grand oh I bet
that you'll be fine without you
so tear your eye or two